hello
arano oregano
parsley
hello Israel hello aiz hello
Meadow yeah it's going well it's going
well hey Perry wow you I haven't seen
you in a long
time how have you been doing how's your
streaming been uh coming
along what's up Jared
is this a
DLC
no no no DLC is
allowed uh hold on for a
second I think I have everything set
up
[Music]
what is
up two years
damn sup P Patrick how how have you
been did I take a break last year I
don't
remember uh so last time we were in reto
Village but I figured I need to farm
some rot
so I thought I might as well uh do some
cave exploration cuz usually you tend to
find oh no maybe that was a mistake with
four hearts and no armor oh
God
goodbye oh oh
rupes I'm going to have to do a lot of
running away during this
playthrough unless I just turn on
infinite Hearts again if it really
becomes too difficult I might just do
that because it's this is for the sake
of recording footage it's not for
playing like Pro
playing my dungeon design videos well to
be to be honest there there have been
some other channels that have been doing
a well just a really really good job at
it
I'm not sure if I maybe I'll I'll do
something like it in the future uh can I
just still still showing black whenever
I do that got to get that fixed at some
point anytime I pull this up it just
creates a black screen I think it's
because of ultra
gam not too
sure uhoh
uhoh
they cannot get me up
here yeah I I might do one I don't know
if I'm going to do one for this game
because I don't think there's too much
to talk about like dungeon wise plus uh
Captain
burgus has been
doing very very good videos on that
oh I can sell
these I only need about like 200 more
rupees so if I can just find some
minerals and things like
that I should be
golden Harry do you still frequent uh
Charlie streams or or
not I I I don't watch Charlie
streams even though he's my he's like
one of my best
friends H sometimes I'll I'll drop by
and lur for for a moment
but
you are the worst friend
ever why he he streams like on Sunday
evenings usually and man I got better
things to
do
uh uh Israel says have you heard of the
music composer theop
Penny Theo Theo penny
yeah they also composed the music for uh
Kaa
right Kaa Bridge of spirits or something
I I don't remember the exact name of the
game
but they they're very good he also did
that Major's mask uh like the final
hours and stuff like
that very very talented for
sure
they would definitely make for a great
composer although they could just use
the composers of the the game as well of
course oh wait I shouldn't waste
materials already
broke uh another
Claymore oh you didn't catch the first
stream that's okay we didn't do I'm I'm
mostly recording footage for an upcoming
video
so uh should get rid of some
stuff do I need a torch not
really oh now now the screen doesn't
turn black all of a
sudden very weird
oh yeah these rocks are very tough I'm
going to break all my tools in
this already bro almost
broken man screw dur
durability
wait uh oh
wait I don't even know if there's
anything worthwhile out behind this
wall
oh more more luminous
Stones uh let's
see is the audio low quality
really well I'm just using the raw mic
I'm not using a pop filter I'm not using
any special post processing or anything
like that
just plug and
play
uh what's the video about it's a
critique of the story of Tears of the
Kingdom like an indepth critique not
just spouting like nonsense I I do
actually want to give
proper you know like arguments
that's the why I don't think the story
is very good so that's that's the
conclusion so I just want to record some
some story elements some uh we might
just get all
the all the memories that might just be
a good
idea
because I'm already running out of
resources down
here what are we doing uh we are
basically
just well right now I'm farming for
rupes because I want to buy some uh
better
clothing uh because we have to go up to
hbra and I don't have enough cold
protection yeah same as the last stream
just going around doing story stuff
skipping most of like I'm barely going
to be doing any
shrines uh let me
see I
am going to look at landing real
quick
this is his real voice yeah this is my
real voice well it's still relatively
fresh right now but as you'll notice
when like as the stream progresses my
voice is going to get
increasingly higher pitch and horse
which is why I cannot record for very
long when I'm working on my videos
uh it sucks it's just the type of voice
I have very very low voice
stamina buy my
stuff just to make you feel better I
I'll play through tears of the Kingdom
right with you well that does make me
feel
better yeah that's
enough
that is
enough I don't need anything else thank
you hey Faraday you made it to a live
stream
yeah yeah yeah my health is fine I've
always had that problem with my voice it
just gets raspy very very quickly the
more I
talk
why does the map FPS look higher than
the game play I'm not sure like this
game is supposed to run at 60 because
this is uh running on
uh
Yuzu because it's just easier I can
easily load save files
and if I see something interesting I can
capture it using the free cam and stuff
but uh yeah it's a bit it's a bit
unstable I don't know if it's my my
graphics card or if maybe some of my
settings are off I I have no
idea maybe it'll improve as more mods
come out
to create more stable
FPS
how do you know I look good in it I
haven't even worn it now I
did oh now you're not going to comment
on my
looks see like the these little hiccups
here and there I I I have no idea what's
going
on I don't think we're going to make
that
yeah it sounds fine now because we just
started but usually like I think the
last stream was 4 hours long and by the
end I could barely string together a
single sentence without my voice just
crackling
up do you think they will use the zonai
in the next game no I don't think
so I don't suspect that they
will cuz they they usually don't revisit
old ideas like the Twilight we've never
seen the twilight
again like they may have they may put in
new
references to the zonai for sure but to
actually feature it N I don't really
think they
will same with the Oka and the the
Minish and the you know all these new
groups or tribes that get introduced
it's usually a oneand done
deal imagine how good tears of the
kingdom and Bre the wild would look on a
switch to granted leaks I don't know
what what what are the leaks I I really
have not paid attention to switch to
related stuff because as far as I know
it's all rumors
right and another weapon
broke can I have them
yeah I think I'm supposed to find tool
in we'll do the memory stuff on a
separate stream I think we'll just
purely focus on getting all the
memories
yeah the Zone I were barely in tears of
the Kingdom to begin
with they showed a demo of breath wild
in
4k
really I did talk to to
he he told me to follow the campfires or
something like
that
can I just ask where where tulan
is they keep a bonfire stoked at the
cave entrance to mark their
location all right that's good to oh no
hey black
links no you were right though because
last time I forgot and I already went to
the location where Tulin is supposed to
be but it he wasn't there so I did all
that for nothing like the last 40
minutes of last uh last week's stream
was completely
useless
wait why did I get
a uh
oh I should probably use
things
yeah wait what's that oh God there's a
whole tribe behind me
run run run run
run he keeps blowing me
away does he have like
a one of those
leaves let me
Che it's a bit of an
annoying setup like this because I if I
want to read chat I have to do like
a almost 90 degree turn to look at my
other
monitor yeah to to be honest I I'll just
wait until switch is announced switch to
and that that'll be the end of
it Kieran Buckley thank you so much uh
which is your favorite Zelda soundtrack
uh probably gudo Valley
still it's it's just it just slaps so
much I don't think this is the right
cave there's no bonfire
here I remember the first time
playing I thought this was
it see what this guy has to
say I think this is a side quest where's
tulan he's out at another cave Gathering
food okay there's a bonfire marking the
entrance you'll find it eventually if
you go west down the mountain
slope West
huh wait is that
it that might be it or is that just a
random Fire
I really do not remember much of this
part of the
game I play Elden ring on a Nintendo
console I double dip well I've got it on
PC so I will just stick to
that still wondering where that DLC is
because people were so sure it was
coming out last
year and I already started questioning
it uh questioning whether or not they
were going to make that because of
armored Core I was like really they're
still it's still slated for 2023 even
though they're working on Armored
Core they're like no no they said they
promised it would be this
year would I ever make another Silent
Hill video I might yeah it is one of my
worst performing videos
ever but still I love Silent Hill I love
me some Silent Hill I'm I'm just a bit
worried for the future of the franchise
because it's it's not been great let's
be honest they sat on this IP for such a
long time without doing anything and now
they're suddenly bombarding us with all
kinds of
crap yeah from softare cooking for sure
it's going to be it it has to be one of
the greatest DLCs right at this point
no I'm not going to show you the way wow
rude very
rude have I ever played Hollow night no
Metroid Vania are not really my
thing unless it's
like like the the the the the 3D games
like the metri prime I will definitely
give that one another
shot like I I kind of enjoyed Metroid
dread for what it was but I'm not like
the biggest I I don't know much about
Metroid uh Metroid in General
so yeah I'm I'm not sure if I would
invest my time in in Hollow night I know
it's good I I know it's good people have
assured me that it's very very
good got to find a
rock I found a
rock
uh which weapon should I
use yeah yeah dread was fun
but I don't know castle like or not
castl Vania Metroid Vania is kind of
confused me a lot of the
time
uhoh
no I think that was Overkill that was a
red one they don't have that much
HP
Rock it's not that I don't like the
exploration but it's like that's all it
is most of the time like the whole game
like I I enjoy games with dungeons where
the the the dungeons themselves are
the the Metroid Vania part of it but
there's also other things but if the
whole game is like that I don't know it
for some reason I just it just doesn't
hold my attention for very
long like granted dread wasn't very
long it wasn't like super long at
least um can I just create an updraft of
something maybe cheese my way through
this
maybe I
can no that's not enough to create
enough tra wait maybe if I throw in a
high and fine
cone
yeah big
brain I knew the pine cones were good
for something but I never I never use it
that
way yeah tears of the Kingdom will let
you cheese cheese through every
Everything
uhoh do I actually have food prepared no
I have not done
anything I'm still sad that Cass was
gone in tears of the Kingdom really
loved him in breath D yeah they kind of
did him dirty didn't they they they just
I don't think they ever even acknowledge
Him someone does reference
him I do remember that but it's like one
sentence if you leave the cave and head
north you can spot a
lone Setter is it Setter cheddar
tree Setter
tree I don't
know yeah pen does mention
him but they never really well they
don't really have to explain where he
went we can kind of like he's a bird he
can go
anywhere like he's a traveling Bard
isn't
he they don't have to explain
everything it's just that he was one of
the cooler
characters from the previous game so to
not see him return that's yeah it's a
shame he is wherever link isn't in
Hyrule yeah he just shows up whenever
I'm not there he's he's actively
avoiding
us man I am low on resources
uhoh I hear some
growlings yeah Penn is cool too he's
he's a decent replacement for for Cass I
would
say are his kids and wife still
here I never actually thought about that
because you you do this whole side quest
with them in uh in in breath of wild
right with the
song where is
Cass his family is still in R Village
and they don't mention him when you talk
to them they're not like oh hey how how
have you
been there he
is how did he lose his bow to this
they're super weak these
monsters taker thank you so much as
always uh would you agree that when they
made Skyward Sword uh in the timeline
they wanted to they wanted Contin
continuity
Jesus but
somehow or no somewhere between sky
sword and breath while their minds
changed I don't know if their minds
changed uh I think Nintendo just goes
with whatever they feel or the Zelda
team rather they just go with whatever
they feel like that week
so when they when they started the
concept for Skyward Sword they were like
we're going to tell a story about The
mastera Sword and then they wrote the
whole thing around
that because you know the the one of the
first things ever we got from skywood
sword was concept art with link andn
F so I'm pretty
sure that's what that was their starting
point and then with breath the wild they
were just like we're going to just start
everything all over again we want to go
back to the first Zelda not focus too
much on story and what little story
there is it's just going to be more like
whatever it's just going to be a goal to
work towards and we're just mostly going
to use the environment to tell little
stories here and there
so I'm I'm not too
sure if there was ever a mind to be made
up if that makes any sense I think
they're just uh doing whatever at this
point the mass sword breaking was cringe
to be honest hated that plot point it is
a bit weird how it never broke before
you could smack it against the wall as
many times as you wanted and now it does
break but it's all because of the weapon
durability it's it's again gameplay
first they know that the the master
sword has to break or else the weapon
durability would be broken as soon as
you get the master sword there's no
reason to find weapons anymore which is
one of the biggest parts of the gameplay
Loop so I get why they did it but yeah
it is lorewise it is a bit
weird uh
let me
see Ganondorf was the most wasted
potential yeah I would say so I I think
they could could have done more with him
for
sure
like uh I said this on the stream last
week like ganador has never been the
greatest villain in my opinion at least
not in arine of time in aan time he he
also kind of suffered from a few issues
where he just kind of like evil for
Evil's sake but they kind of corrected
that with the Wind
Waker like when they wrote the like
someone did a really good job in the
writing staff with Wind Waker because
they actually decided to give Ganondorf
more of a human side to
him and of course Twilight Princess yeah
I mean it was just cool to see him there
but like as the puppet master was like
behind everything but he he never I
don't think they ever intended him to
have a giant role he was just there to
have one final twist slash boss
fight and he did compliment zand's
character very well because zand was
zand starts out as a really badass
villain and then at the end you kind of
realize he's kind of pathetic which the
first time I hated
that but in hindsight I actually like
after giving it more thought it actually
is a pretty genius way of doing
it because the only thing that made Zen
powerful was his borrowed power from
from
[Music]
Ganondorf the most played sound effect
in the entire game Tulin tornado I think
that's what it's called right
I think they call it that in
uh age of Calamity
DLC I think Ganon would work as a
psychotic murderer like like in the
backstory of A Link to the Past you mean
where he like just straight up kills all
his own
henchmen like they paint a really really
dark picture of him in that backstory
where Like Blood Stained hands he grabs
the Triforce
zanot shafted well I think that was kind
of the point
right I I think it's an interesting
Dynamic to be honest
cuz you know that classic saying like
everyone has to answer to someone that
like or like there's always a bigger
fish well in Zan's
case his
entire stick was that he his power was
just
borrowed wait did my bow break oh yeah
it did
again
uh but you know I I I understand like I
said the first time I hated it too I was
like man he was so cool with the mask
and all like everything
and oh I have motion controls I
forgot
uh oh uh oh that guy will definitely
kill me in one hit if he gets the
chance
wo are he still frozen how long do they
stay frozen
actually oh well I guess that answers
our
question the neck crack at the end of
Twilight Princess oh yeah yeah
yeah that was
iconic Captain Doge says I love Tulin
what an adorable little bean of a
character he's less arrogant than I
thought he would be like when they first
introduce him he's kind of like stubborn
and I thought he was going to be like
ravali 2.0 but even worse because he's
he's a kid and no nothing's worse than a
stuck
up like arrogant little kid but he
actually turns out to be quite
humble
Mr Andrew Mr Andrew oh wait that's a
Anderson I think the problem with tears
of the kingdom is not the story itself
but rather the structure
uh if it narration oh the structure of
it narration and a lack of explanation
whether it be indirect or
direct well that's pretty much the story
right like a story is made up of things
like structure consistency character
growth C character portrayal I guess you
could say
uh in my in my mind at least that's
those are all ingredients that make up a
story and some of them
are H they don't really work very well
but you are right like the structure
definitely hurts it the most the whole
uh you need to be able to go anywhere
but you also have to experence uh
experience a
story there have been games that have
already tackled that problem
before there are open world games out
there right now that have done a very
very good job at
that and I don't know if Nintendo played
those or saw them or is aware of
them but it it can be
done
like if if they want to go with the open
World stuff because I I've seen some
people make the argument and say that
Zelda has always been it's always meant
to be open world and I I don't really
agree with that like Zelda can be any
like at least in my opinion it can be
anything and it has taken on almost
every type of gamep play style
imaginable as well as every graphic
style at this point except maybe ultra
realistic which I hope they they will
never do I kind of like the weird art
styles that
they that they experiment
with well yeah Zelda is about expiration
for sure but you can explore in a non-op
world game
too like a Metroid Vania for example I
wouldn't consider that open world
necessarily but like before it's not
just technical Li limitations of course
it's also just Nintendo experimenting
with
things they've done multiplayer they've
done like I said pretty much everything
with Zelda at this point and and I I
think that's important I think it's
important that this series stays fresh
if we're just going to get open world
after open world after like every time
it's just going to be the same then give
or take like a decade from now Zelda is
going to grow very very stale the fact
that it's been able to survive for such
a long time like 30 what is it 35 years
now 36 is because it keeps mixing it
up
so yeah like the the first Zelda was
meant to be open world and just go
wherever do
whatever but Zelda has grown beyond that
at some point it's been doing so many
different things Zelda can be anything
in my mind as long as it's got good
gamep play and hopefully some good lore
to to to boot that would be amazing as
well 38 years this year
damn
it's
crazy I don't know any open air games
with a great story is it uh ignorance of
mine no no no absolutely not well open
air I mean the open air is kind of a
term that Nintendo
coined it's kind of a sales gimmick
because it's just open world at at that
point of
course but I mean there's plenty of open
world games that have good stories
sure uh should I drop something should I
drop my
hoe I'll just drop the
stick
uh wait why does it say oh that's
another emulator problem I
think give me
the
yes
uh maybe the next Zelda game comes out
for the 40th anniversary copium oh well
maybe if they can make Majora's Mask in
barely a
year a little over a year then they
could definitely do it
again open in terms of progression you
mean like
uh well like the the the ideal option is
that you don't limit people from going
anywhere in the world you you can still
bar off certain sections like for
example you cannot enter a certain
castle without the proper key or
something but you should at least be
able to get there and find that out
instead of someone being like hey you
should go to the castle over
there I missed the chest uh probably not
important
then I just want to get through this so
I can get to the story elements and hit
record
whenever uh is there
anything
no
well the ocean in the Wind Waker was
just a floating loading screen in
Disguise yeah kind of well that for that
one they have said it was due to
technical limitations that they wanted
to do more with it but you know the wind
wer mix up for it with the whole like
the island aesthetic
and I always liked
it I I like the idea because the sea is
really like that you know the sea is
mostly just
a big stretch of nothing in every
direction what that's what's so scary
about the ocean in
general that's why I don't sail I'd
rather crash with an airplane than I
would
like being on a sinking ship just the
idea is really terrifying
cuz you're going to have time to think
about what's happening to
you and because it's something that
comes kind of close to me
uh I
actually had a group of friends who
disappeared on the
ocean never to be seen
again well I wouldn't call them friends
no more like very good good
acquaintances yeah it was pretty crazy
crazy news back
then someone should make him documentary
about that because it's such an
insignificant part of history but it's
actually quite
interesting because usually the
Netherlands doesn't make it to top news
anywhere like worldwide top
news what is tuling what is the tooling
doing uh let me see another problem that
bothered me a bit with my first
playthrough of Tears of the kingdom is
that the environmental storytelling
feels
meaningless uh there's a very there's a
few good ones but overall the Overworld
feels thoughtless well that's because
it's the same map
and the things that are there you
already know where they are first of all
so
you're you're you're all at least if you
played breath wild of course you're
going to be you're you're going to know
where you have to go
already and they just didn't make enough
changes to
it like a cola Citadel there's nothing
really to find that's new about it
cannot even enter it not really there's
like one room where you can find a chest
I
think like breath wild just had the
advantage of the whole map being new
everything was new so you never knew
what what was going to be behind the
next mountain or Ridge or
whatever
but there was so much to find if you if
you did some
investigating
uh there we
go JJ creeper Aster in age of Calamity
was more interesting than Ganondorf
inters of the Kingdom well yeah at least
he did stuff he was active in the story
a lot
more
like the it worked for Calamity Ganon
because he's just a Mindless force and
he was basically sealed at that
point but here yeah I know he does have
to regain his
strength but he can create Phantoms he
can can do all kinds of stuff but he
doesn't really show up all that all that
often he doesn't impact the story all
that
much plus Aster just had a really good
voice actor you know
and I know gondorf does too but they
rarely use
it he doesn't have enough lines if
you're going to use Mt Mercer come on
man let let the guy speak a little bit
more this is fun with one stamina
wheel taker thank you again what are the
odds that we see some kind of remake
remaster of AR of time maur's mask Wind
Waker or Twilight Princess before we see
the next Mainline game on the new
platform or on the next
platform
uh I don't know
man it takes a long time to do an actual
remake and I don't know if they would
trust any any Studio to do
that cuz arine of Time
3D and Twilight Princess uh HD and all
that stuff that's still using the same
sour source code and an engine it's just
souped up and and made
better in in most cases not not in every
case of course especially Arina time in
the's mask they did some questionable
things
but I do like the I do think the
graphical upgrade is really
good
I didn't really like age of Calamity
story in the
beginning because it it was supposed to
be uh I thought they were gen uh
genuinely going to tell like tell the
story of 100 years ago but it was just
time travel again so it's an alternate
timeline but that's also because it's a
muso
game I do think it was okay at least at
least I don't have the same complaints
that I would have with this story with
age of Calamity for
sure yeah grezzo did add a lot of
details to uh the 3DS remakes so yeah
take her to uh to get back to your
question I don't really know if they
will pour in the
effort like a remaster or a port yeah
sure but an actual remake
especially after they've already done
arine of Time 3D and maor's mask 3D
3D not too
sure I know there's rumors about it
but I also don't really see the point to
be honest just make a new 2D Zelda game
in that
case if if you want to do something more
low effort that takes a little bit less
time just make a brand new 2D game
instead to hold us over until the next
3D
game I don't really
see why people want stuff to be remade
so very so often if it's still playable
if the original is still playable if
it's
available I think it's a bit weird but
that you know I've never been a big fan
of remakes in
general like I'm sure there's a lot of
people are happy with stuff like the
Resident Evil four
remake
but the the original four is still
really
good just Port it to PC just give it a
little bit of a graphical
overhaul up skill some of the textures
you can use AI for that stuff
nowadays the fact that it was nominated
even for game of the year was
already quite quite
questionable I think I personally think
a of time even is
still just it's still playable it's
still fine yeah I mean graphically it
doesn't
look that great
but now that we have a enough time on uh
like we have decompile well not we some
very dedicated dedicated individuals
have reverse engineered AR of time and
decompiled its source code the modern
Community is going to be creating
texture packs all kinds of little life
uh you know quality of life improvements
overall it's going to look great and
it's going to play better you can put
the iron boots as a as an actual face
button
item hey Matthew
cheers I will cheers you with my
uh my bottle of
water well in this case Nintendo is not
doesn't really have anything to say
about it not anymore at least AR of time
is so old
now it's sold a bajillion
games just try and stop it from
spreading at this point because you
don't even need an emulator anymore not
really uh well you do need an emulator
but it's it's not running on Native code
anymore it's just I think it's running
on
C sharp I'm I'm not too sure
sure check uh don I'm planning to visit
the Netherlands uh is the Netherlands
expensive an expensive place to visit no
not really it's not it's not that
bad I mean everywhere is expensive now
because of inflation and all that stuff
but it yeah it's it's it's a it's doable
it's definitely not as bad as Norway or
Switzerland like Germany Netherlands
Belgium France they're all very
affordable
so yeah do it but do try to visit during
either spring or summer
because right now it's cold it's rainy
it's gray it's not the greatest place to
be we have a very boring autumn and
winter
yeah this part of the game is
great it's probably the best leadup to
any of the four
dungeons although the yeah I think the
it's better than the grudo one although
the G one is a very close
second
uh do I go up here
first oh wait I can
just no
yes
this is definitely one ability that I'm
I'm going to
miss if it doesn't return the the Ascend
is really really
handy uh let's see I think I have to go
to that one
first but I cannot climb that one so
I guess I need to break those wait what
what was the point of coming up here
then cuz I can just get there
anyway go around
it do you prefer a battle with lios or
gleo oh definitely gleo
uh I fought so many lios in bre the wild
I was already sick of them at that
point go on the platforms on the other
side like that those
or the other other
side there's a hole with
icicles you mean that one right
there or you mean
those I'm assuming you you mean
those
come on Tulin do
something oh there's a call at the door
downstairs uh I think my fiance is
got theorists took a lot of L's with
tears of the Kingdom I wonder if that
contributed to the dislike of the game
uh at all well that depends on what you
enjoy about Zelda if you're not at all
if you don't care about lore and story
then you're going to
just the like this game is just going to
be amazing in every single way
if you do care about story on lore yeah
there is going to be a chance that you
you aren't going to appreciate it as
much and I think a lot of the Zelda
theorists obviously like I don't know
any Zelda theorist that is just doing it
for the
views and just for for money like the
all the
theorists do it because they love the
they genuinely love the lore of this
series do I wait what do I do here
forgot he
[Music]
hey well I I definitely uh I know from
talking to other people like for some
people this game really kind of ruined
their creativity for a while and they're
just also like obviously the the the
biggest example is Bandit Bandit
games like he's just outright like I'm
not going to do Theory videos on this
because I don't find it interesting and
I you know I respect
that for me for me it's like yeah well
that there goes my
voice like for me it's kind of like I
fall somewhere in the middle I I will
still be doing videos on this game if I
feel like I have something to say but it
is going to be a little bit harder to
come up with ideas to talk
about but I'm I'm not going to like
outright ban this game from my lore list
or anything like that that's
uh that's going a bit too far
CU there are some things in this game
that are interesting at least in my
opinion oh I'm not going to make
that can I break this
yes I don't don't have any
more bomb arrows but maybe fire arrows
will
work I don't think you need to like I
think you can just use vanilla vanilla
arrows what's not interesting
[Music]
about just because the new gon is not
his childhood
gon I'm not sure what we're talking
about
here the seven people who didn't play
breath of the wild were were the ones
that enjoy tears of the Kingdom the most
yeah yeah yeah probably I think you're
you're on to something
there although I do I think breal still
has his
place I think if you just play these two
games back to back it's going to be fine
for most
people
oh they just die in one hit they're
they're so underwhelming this
enemy remember seal Ganon
yeah I mean it didn't it did end up
being about a seal on Ganon but it had
very very little to do with
uh with that
theory the text did not say seal gon at
all
but it was a fun little
idea I can see where I need to
go shik attack being removed is
posible
well the shik attack I don't mind that
it's gone they just could have come up
with a little bit of a better
explanation as to why it's gone because
this game is supposed to take place like
five or six
years after breath wild if I recall
might be a little more or less I'm not
sure but they could have just been like
hey you know we we we just decided to
remove all of it
just clean it all clean the whole thing
up it's too dangerous we've been burned
once if if Ganon ever comes back he's
going to just take over the machines
again and we're going to be
screwed so you know over the last five
or six years they've just been
repurposing
it disarming it making it no longer
viable as a weapon
or you can still find like a a big trash
heap of of old Guardians
that that would be cool to just say like
oh it
disappeared I don't buy that sorry I
just don't buy it like who programmed
the all the shika machines in a way that
they would all just disappear as soon as
Ganondorf would be or Calamity Ganon
would be defeated and why didn't it
disappear 10,000 years
ago when they actually defeated Ganon
with it
like why would the shika even program
that and how would they program that
into their technology like even the
shrines
like even the the whole Shrine of
Resurrection it just went up in
smoke I'm going to die here if I engage
with these guys I have no armor I have
no
weapons ow
I have no
food uh wait that's not eating them
uh have have people figured out the Zone
I texts uh I know zeldor has been trying
it for a while now well Zelda lore
hasn't really been trying well maybe
he's interested in the topic but there's
a whole Reddit where they where you have
actual people mapping it mapping the
whole thing up like I'm sure he's also
contributing in a way but he's not at
the Forefront of it as far as I'm I'm
aware but the conclusion that people
have drawn at least at this point is
it's it's gibberish it doesn't mean
anything people have tried for sure
there's a there's a Reddit for it it's
called TK Lang so tears of the Kingdom
language I
guess uh where do I go from
here there's nothing below here right
no like I'm sure you can you can come up
with all kinds of excuses as to why the
shik technology
would disappear
suddenly like it's not like it's
impossible to find anything like some
sort of weird Theory or whatever but is
it is it logical is it plausible I don't
think
so like as much as I enjoy Zelda
theories that are a little bit out there
there is a there is a limit to what I
consider to
be uh like is it still going to be a
good story after that or is it going to
make sense after
that oh wait that one was already
dead no no no don't you dare blow away
my zai
charges
I don't think he's coming up here he
doesn't see me anymore he's going to go
back down
yeah it's just like with conspiracy
theories you know like
a lot of conspiracy theories can be very
exciting and they can be very cool and
if they stay in that perfect little
realm of possibilities yeah like yeah
maybe they do have crashed aircraft or
like spacecrafts in Area
51 you know but as soon as you have to
stretch the truth as soon as you start
to incorporate all kinds of weird Globe
spanning conspiracies where it it just
doesn't work anymore where there's it
would be too difficult to keep a secret
at that point I'm like
nah we're done here this theory is not
going to
work like I'm finding it hard to put
into words that that's why I don't do
debates with
people cuz all the best AR uments always
come to me afterwards like long after
the the the whole debate is
over
what but that's why I make scripted
videos because then I get time to put
things into smarter words than I am able
to convey when I'm just
improvising because I'm not a very good
public speaker at all oh there's a
chest
yeah I see that idea black Reaper but uh
it supposedly already disappeared long
before the seal was broken
right at least that's what I got out of
it
but oh thank you
uh
nosrat that's good to
hear like I know I cannot hide behind
that forever but it is still something
that
people forget sometimes that I'm not a
native English speaker words go from
Dutch to English in my head first before
I I utter
them and sometimes I just don't know the
the right words to say something
but I do know when how I feel about some
things
and I'm always open to a discussion just
with people in a friendly manner of
course but on podcasts whatever podcast
wraps up I'm always like man I wanted to
say so much more or better things but I
I I just couldn't find the
words or I forgot
yeah the depths are are definitely the
coolest when it's still dark when you
light it up it's no longer as
imposing for me that's it's more that
the depths should have been smaller more
packed with content instead of just
stretching across the whole map
cuz there's no way they're going to be
able to fill all that stuff with unique
stuff that's why you get a lot of
repeat uh
content like you get your typical
bobblin camps everywhere and almost
every building you find in the depths
has a duplicate or multiple of them like
the coliseums and the mines and you know
that's because it's so
huge I think if they just kept it a
little a little bit smaller if for
example every Province had their own
little depths
portion I think that that would have
already made a huge cuz when you repeat
something it the original loses its
charm that's just how it works you know
if you find a another one of
those it's not going to be as
interesting
anymore like if you only had one
Coliseum that would already be more
interesting
as soon as you introduce five more
coliseums it's just going to be like
okay it's it's this
again I just don't think they would have
had time to fill up the whole depths
with like chalk full with unique stuff I
I'm I'm convinced that they just didn't
have the time for
that maybe they would have wanted to
but oh no
no oh I'm going to
fall I am definitely going to
fall and I'm gone oh God yeah I'm gone
no I'm I'm going to have to start all
over
again
there's nothing I can do oh wait I can
warp at least to this Shrine yeah it's
not that bad it's only a small part that
I have to do
over when you jump you the the the ship
keeps going but you
stop which is a bit weird aren't you
isn't the momentum supposed to carry
over to you you as well isn't that how
that is that not
fitex have you tried tunic yeah yeah I
have it on my uh on my switch I haven't
finished it yet but I'm I actually don't
know how far I am but I I feel like I
played it for a for a
while it's very difficult I think I I
know I said that in the last stream
right I think I'm
almost yeah it's a very difficult
game it's a it's a Souls it's it's more
a Souls likee than it is a Zelda game
aesthetically it looks like a Zelda game
but it plays like a
Souls Souls Bor and souls
like tears of the kingdom is pretty
anti-
completionist
what you mean like charity fraud I'm
sorry I just cannot read the word
completionist anymore and not think
about that he has tarnished the word
completionist for
me but yeah I I know what you mean I
know what you
mean but I think that's kind of the
point right that wasn't that already the
point with uh breath the wild back then
where it's like you're not supposed to
find all the cororo seeds and if you
still go through with it anyway because
you're crazy then you're not going to
get anything for it you're not going to
get any acknowledgement from Nintendo in
fact they will spit in your face with a
a golden
turd we need a new term for
completionist
yeah let's change an entire term because
of some one one person
[Music]
oh I don't have any more arrows oh I
don't have to shoot the
icicles I didn't know
that Christian says Don I'm so glad that
you're having fun playing through tears
of the Kingdom again but on
unfortunately it just isn't for me well
I'm playing through it because I'm
trying to capture footage for all the
the the the story elements for a video
that I'm making but under normal
circumstances I probably wouldn't play
this game at least for
another few years before I gave it
another
try I I have so much other stuff that I
want to
play I'm currently playing escape from
tarov with my cousins uh my friends I
should say not just my
cousins with uh with a group of people I
think Charlie is also going to going to
be
joining next
time very very difficult
game but it is pretty cool
would you collect donations for 10
years are you talking about the whole uh
completionist stuff no well even if I
did I would at least be transparent
about it and be like hey you know like
just so so you know the money that
you're donating it's not going to go to
anything anytime soon we're going to try
to hit a million first and then we're
going to donate it like that that would
have if he if he would have done that
that would have completely there would
be no
drama that would have been it like it's
it's still a bit of a questionable way
to handle donations but at least you're
being upfront about
it but no I would not collect your
donations for 10 years without telling
you like I I switched sides a couple of
times during that whole debacco because
in the beginning I was like well let's
first hear his side you know people were
so easy to immediately call him the
worst human being and I hate when people
do that before they get a chance to let
the other side defend
themselves it's just something this it's
just common courtesy to just give
someone the opportunity to to explain
themselves you know like what happened
why uh maybe they have some very good
arguments or good reasons why they did
what they
did I mean there's been a couple of
examples of people being accused of
stuff and then it turned out like it was
just either the other side was lying or
it was just all a big misunderstanding
or
whatever but yeah after he came out with
his confession or with his apology I
should
say the that's the point where I was
like okay yeah
um I am no longer a fan of this
guy because I I did watch his videos
from time to time and I'm I used to
watch scary uh scary game Squad a lot I
still do because I moved on without him
without
Gerard yeah the Bayonetta stuff for
example is a very good that's a very
good example in
fact oh keep forgetting I don't have my
bow ow
I would say the projared situation was
also
similar where he was just being accused
of some really horrendous stuff and it
ended up
being kind of
overblown to put it
lightly sometimes you just got got to
well you always have to give people the
opportunity to
uh to respond first before you go
completely you're the worst human being
ever It's always important to do I I
would want that opportunity at least
because anyone can say anyone about
everything about me
too they could make up anything and
before get a chance to respond the half
the the internet will already think I
must come
back it's how how it
works he's back to making content really
he's pulling a Sniper
Wolf oh no wait not Sniper Wolf uh the
other one
Illuminati she also just continues to
make she's like well I might as well
just try
to get some more views in the meantime
before I completely get removed off the
platform did he get personal gains with
the money I I honestly at this point I
don't know I really don't know if it if
he
did
like he did they did donate a very large
sum so for sure it wasn't sitting like
he didn't buy a Ferrari with it or
something like that the neither did any
of his family but there is still some
money that's unaccounted for
allegedly something about a golf
tournament or something I I don't
know
oh I could have warped to this one too
right I did activate this one oh man I
did way too
much I played this whole stream is just
going to me be me trying to get to the
first
dungeon did you ever try magic mushrooms
no I do not have the mental fortitude to
uh deal with that kind of stuff I have
Panic anxiety disorder if I if reality
start warping around me for sure I will
Panic like that would not be a pleasant
experience for
me that would just be
horrible I know myself well enough like
anything hallucinate like
hallucinogens related would not work
very well on
me
plus I'm kind of like in a different
stage in life right now where I don't
really do anything like I barely even
drink alcohol at that at this
point which granted is mostly because of
IBS but still I'm actually enjoying not
drinking oh am I going to make the same
mistake I think I
am oh no wait I think that's my saving
Grace
[Music]
Oho well it's just the hangovers man
it's it's the
worst you're borrowing you're when it
comes to anything like alcohol drugs
where whatever like I mean do whatever
you want to do but I have found out over
the course of my my life that you're
basically just borrowing happiness from
the next day so you will feel feel worse
and I actually enjoy every day just
being nice
now and not waking up and feeling like
oh my God everything is terrible for
like the first 12
hours
I mean people can ask me anything when
it like I will give you an honest answer
when it comes
to normal questions I think that's
pretty normal
question I mean you watch streams to get
to know someone a little bit more too as
well not just to see them play a game
right
okay I I I did have a moment in my life
where I I lived the Rock and
Roll Lifestyle because I was literally
doing rock and
roll like with a with with my band and
just playing in a lot of pubs so so
obviously there's going to be a lot of
beer and stuff but you know oh this is
this is
one of the best
moments where you dive into the eye of
the storm this is so
cool like this is definitely a highlight
I can see why they put this as the quote
unquote first dungeon or at least the
the dungeon they they nudge you towards
the
most quit alcohol just use puff shrooms
from now
on yeah
uh beer beard dxy that's a cool name
beard Aly uh I
play um mainly guitar electric
guitar uh and bass but I play bass like
a guitarist so it's it's kind of
cheating but yeah my my last the last
band uh I was in they already had two uh
guitarists
so I accepted
base but I'm more I'm definitely
more guitar
focused yeah the swelling of the music
in this part is
great I just seeing the the silhouette
of the storm Ark as you dive into the
eye of the storm is really cool they
really did a good job on
that
maed pan says the dungeons were better
than the Divine beasts but still not as
good as proper structured dungeons in
the older games oh for sure
yeah I think the Divine beasts were cool
but not like again like like I said with
the previous example if you do it four
times if you if you're doing something
multiple times it loses it
charm so suppose you had four dungeons
of which one of them was a Divine Beast
then it would have stood out and it
might have even been a a favorite a fan
favorite dungeon in in general because
it's Unique it's new it's the only one
of its kind but doing the same thing
four times yeah then because uh with
breath wild my first Divine Beast was
VAB Boris and just seeing that tail
section rise up and the the the neck of
the Divine Beast rise up and just the
sheer size of it I I had never seen
something like that in a video game
before maybe
like uh people who played uh what's it
called
again like things like God of War but
also Shadow of the Colossus there maybe
a little bit more use to that kind of
thing like where just you're on this
huge moving thing but for me that was
new and the fact that it was
mechanical and you had the rings that
you had to turn it it was just overall
was a very very good uh dungeon albe it
a little short for a typical Zelda
dungeon and that's kind of the problem
with these dungeons is that they are
aesthetically more pleasing or more
unique but it's just the Divine like
mechanically it's just a Divine Beast
again just activate the five or four
thingies and and you're good to go and
they show up on your map again you're
just following dots dotts on a
map pretty sure
right
yeah yeah it's the it's the exact
same
bra minus the boss the boss is better
for sure the boss battles are the on the
miles better than they were in breath of
the wild use your power to release all
five locks and the hatch should
open soor I'm recording this in the
meantime they're just too short there's
too
simplistic they are cool in concept when
you first discover like oh this game has
actual dungeons but then you explore
them and it's like yeah it's not it's is
it
really I wouldn't say
so it's like 1/4 of a classic Zelda
dungeon I think the lightning one was
the best probably
that's the one I found the
best uh yeah cuz I'm pretty sure yeah
it's just like follow the dot it shows
you where it
is just go
there for a game that's all about not
having objective markers or not
following objective markers I think
before someone said uh if I I played the
Xenoblade games I don't know who that
was uh but yeah I've played all of them
well not all of them obviously the Xeno
Blade Games not the Zeno Series in
general I didn't like X very
much but the one two three are all
great uh what was it again oh
yeah
yeah the music here is
great see the blade three is the best
one uh if you also count the DLC then
yes without the
DLC I still prefer
two it to me just because of the ending
and just the whole final segment of two
was so like on the beant stock was so
good in the land of Mora
and oh and the music there was so so
amazing as
well yeah Xeno Blade one is my brother's
favorite I think as well if I recall
like he's he's the one who got me into
Xenoblade and I'm
dead I really need to upgrade my armor
and get get some better some more Hearts
I don't think I'm going to do the whole
game without infinite am or
infinite uh Hearts because I'm just
going to be recording my video will
never come out at that point like last
stream I AC accidentally had infinite
Hearts turned on but now I see that it
might actually be better if I continue
that it is my first death
though it's
impressive three is far more tame
compared to two yeah I would say
so but with the DLC the DLC that
compliment it very very
well yeah aside from the weird Parts I
know what you mean I know know exactly
which parts you are talking about but
aside from that it was really really
good oh my God just
die okay thank
you but I like all of them all
the the story Xeno
blades excluding
X try lies of pie you will not regret it
I I am interested to try it especially
after Elder ring
yeah look
good looks
good I don't think I need an ax
ax ax was mad weird I just didn't like
that it had nothing to do with the
other
games it is a very impressive open world
that they created though like isn't it
still one of the biggest Maps ever
created it's like still in the top five
or
something yeah it's not uh Li Liza Pai
is more like bloodborne yeah I I I agree
it's not like Elden ring but just Elder
ring got me into the whole Souls
series I did play Dark Souls 3 for a
very very short amount of
time uh before starting Elder ring just
to get an idea of what the controls are
going to be like and the combat was
going to be like but I never finished
Dark Souls 3 because I
suck I couldn't get past the abyss
Watchers I still haven't been able to
get get past
them
yeah the you can hear the VTO tune in
this one
true get over
here any Souls game recommendations I
only played demon souls in Alm ring oh
you played de Demon Souls well then Dark
Souls One Two Three or one and
three bloodborne
SEO just all the from soft
games I'm sure there's a lot
of other nonr soft games that are but I
mean from soft is the best it's just the
best JJ creeper says Elden ring is one
of the best or one of the greatest games
I've ever made I wholeheartedly
agree we should play Elden ring on
stream sometime I love embarrassing
myself in front of you
guys wow how did I not get hit by those
lasers I don't think the next Zelda game
has to be bigger than tear of the
kingdom it just needs to be more
focused
CU size is not always more important
when it comes to the world some of the
best open World Games don't necessarily
have the
biggest map you know what I
mean like you can have 10 really really
good quests that keep going going on
forever and they all lead to their own
very separate very exciting story lines
like Side Stories or you can have a
hundred fetch quests where it's just
like oh I I I need Flint to open up my
company but I'm too lazy to go up the
mountain can can you do it for me
instead like that's not fun nobody likes
that we accept it as part of open world
games but nobody actually en you cannot
tell me you actually enjoy unless the
fetch Quest itself leads into something
bigger like oh can you get this for me
from that cave and then it ends up like
turning into this hole weird conspiracy
uncovering or
something then it's okay but just purely
being like get me 50 logs of wood it's
just a waste of
time it's just
filler that's why I hate when uh uh
developers come out and say things like
our game is like uh like 150 hours of
gameplay before you're done with it I'm
like well that doesn't mean
anything is it going to be 150 boring
hours or is it going to be 150 Fun hours
because that's what's more important to
me
anyway I loved watching that episode of
rater's podcast with you and it I agree
with almost everything in it oh thank
you well I mean uh the you mean the
first one or the second one cuz we did
two and I think on the second one we
were even more harsh towards this game
than we were in the first
one cuz the first one it was still kind
of like a first impression kind of
deal of course we're talking about story
we we're not talking about game play
gameplay wise it's
fine tell this to anuma I don't think
anuma cares what other people think
especially
people in the west or
YouTubers he's got better things to
do
uh oh yeah you cannot go here from this
side any know what I think it's fine if
he
doesn't if the Zelda team keeps doing
their own thing
because at the end of the day they will
just do what they want
anyway and that's also what led to a lot
of great
things and why is all that so unique so
let let them let them do what what they
want to do let them give give us
something that we didn't know we
wanted oh the new one with the Zelda
complaints well we did one uh we did one
before although yeah that was also a
podcast I was not a live stream but that
that was like after the game was out for
only about two months what three
months yeah let let them cook for
sure
absolutely that that's what we talked
about last stream as well is like even
if you really do not like this game like
so I think someone came out and said
something on the lines of
like like tears of the Kingdom ruined
the franchise I'm like no it didn't ruin
anything it it at most you did not like
this
game which is totally
fine but it it it didn't ruin
anything Zelda 2 did not ruin the
franchise no nothing ruins it until it's
it becomes something consistent if they
keep failing over and over again then
yeah at that point you can say like
the series had a downfall
but one bad game or one game that
doesn't resonate with you I should say
because obviously this is not a a bad
game it's just either it's it works for
you or it
doesn't Zelda to is
underrated I don't know I wanted to say
something
harsh I think it deserved every bit of
criticism that it got for sure hey
Tulin oh goes right through
him I do think it deserved its
criticisms for sure especially after
Zelda
1 I appreciate that they tried something
new and then just play it safe which
would go on to kind kind of Define the
Zelda series in general so Touche on
that
one but yeah I think it does have major
major
flaws I I play played it for a fair bit
but I I just cannot get through that
game try as I
might not because it's too hard because
i' I've played harder NES games I've
beaten Ninja Garden on NES I've beaten
the first Castlevania and Super
Castlevania which is not NES but screw
it I'm going to I'm going to flex on
with that one as
well so it's not like it was too hard it
was just so cryptic where where you'll
just like how was anyone supposed to
know this without a guy
like it's almost like this game was made
to sell Nintendo
power or any other equivalent to
Nintendo power in your country cuz we
did not have Nintendo Power we had
Nintendo Power
[Music]
unlimited which is totally not the same
thing uh I need
icicles where can I find icicles
or I can just glue a weapon to
it I can
just glue one of my weapons too I
think that's not what I
wanted there we
go can I get my weapon back actually
from
here I would really appreciate that
yeahoo
oh I'm going to get stabbed to death
right away after pulling that
move
uh next Zelda is going to be about the
blood
moon uh maybe I thought they were going
to explain the origin of the blood moon
in this one but they did
not they in fact did not oh God God
God he was a
weakling right
why the blood
moon uh I don't
know we will go to the blood moon the
whole game will take place on the
moon just like Major's mask but the
whole game will be like that like the
final
segment
uh Master Koga went to space yeah the
next game is going to be about master
Koga surviving in space no link no Zelda
no Ganondorf it's all going to be about
master
Koga I forgot he did a Team
Rocket uh let's see where's the last one
or last two
ones there's one all the way at the
bottom I remember that
one to infinity and
beyond think I can make that
right
are you going to hit me
now I
even uh where's
Tulin where's
Tulin actually what did you guys think
of the companion stuff in this game
just the fact that you have to do the
dungeons with someone else like with an
AI I think I even mentioned that in one
of my videos where I was like you know I
just the fact that I I'm not given the
option to just go into these dungeons
alone it's kind of
it's kind of a little bit of a bummer to
me cuz I like just being on my own when
I do a Dungeon Crawl I don't want to
have ai
Partners at least not with a game like
that maybe with the DND type of game
it's different because it's all about
party management and
stuff but not like with a third person
action RPG whatever you want to call it
like
this
like the first time when when I got to
the lightning Temple which again vanab
Boris was my first Divine Beast
lightning Temple was my first dungeon
and I just uh remember like I I just
want needed to keep that tradition but
yeah I was in front of the entrance and
I was like oh you're coming with
me
man I actually want to go in here by
myself it looks
cool I don't want you to be following me
everywhere uh
uh the last one is
here this is the stairway to downstairs
oh there's another opening on the other
side
okay
Wind Waker did the partner thing better
than tears of the Kingdom well at least
you could leave the your partner behind
but even there I did not really like
it even there I was like ah just go away
I don't want to be keeping track of
where you are and what you're doing and
I some want to explore this place
man I know it makes for some like of
those D Dynamic
puzzles can you defeat this cannon
thingy or is that not an
option
sir do you have time to talk about our
Lord and savior
hilia I can cannot shoot through these
right oh I do in a lot of games it will
just be like an invisible
wall he cannot cannot touch me and he's
dead I'm assuming you just you you don't
like some of Wind Waker Dungeons and uh
I like them but the partner stuff did
not contribute to that to
to my me liking it in fact it kind of
hurt it a little bit but the Earth
Temple was really cool The Forbidden
forests was very
awesome I really love the Forbidden
Forest just the atmosphere it's one of
my favorite dungeons in terms of
atmosphere purely purely
atmosphere the floaty particl of all of
it the
music it's not nearly like it's
definitely not my favorite dungeon by
any means
but I just like
the the atmosphere that's what
it temp yeah Temple of the Gods is
really good
too
[Music]
uh let me see oh yeah icicle time
again whoever said the depths didn't
have a lot to discover I don't know who
said that
I did probably at some
point but most of the stuff you're
listing off are just Collectibles H it's
just things you have to
find that doesn't necessarily make for
like when people like if you enjoy that
kind of stuff like power to you but when
people are talking
about uh like there like there's nothing
to the depths they're mostly talking
about
like lorewise or either lorewise or just
like big
discoveries like yeah collecting pose is
fine and all but oh it did
work come on
Tulin like I'm I'm not a big fan of
collectons so for me the depths are
mostly just
there the first time entering it is
really cool for sure and the the music
is
cool and especially when it's still
pitch black and you don't know what's
going to be lurking in the
dark uh but it kind of for me it did
lose its charm a bit after a
while cuz like okay it's another
Coliseum it's another mine it's another
thing that I've already seen
before and the most of the bosses there
are just the dungeon
bosses aside from the frocks the frogs
was a nice surprise for sure I like the
frogs the the the big
one the first time I saw one I
immediately booked it out of there
I think that was on the way to the
lightning Temple so I was
still at like four or five hearts at
that point I had almost
nothing why were the sky islands not
visible in bre
wild
uh Cloud
barrier I I don't even know if that's if
they would remember the cloud barrier
but
like if you if you're curious about what
I would have SE would have what I would
have liked from the
depths then I would really advise that
you play Elden
ring cuz Elden ring is a perfect example
of what what the underground should have
been cuz in Elden Rings Elden Rings
underground is huge as well but it
doesn't span the entire map that would
be that would be way too much but what
is there is like there's tons of hidden
bosses every area is
unique get blown away
L gotcha tul actually before I uh fight
this guy I really really really have to
go to the bathroom real quick or else by
the time I finally beat this guy I'm
going to explode so just give me five
minutes and I will be right back or two
minutes should do it I'll just put it on
the waiting screen for people who
join and think wait where is he what's
going on I always forget to put it on
the waiting screen oh wait that's
stream's starting soon no be right back
it's the one that I
need there we
go
even Skyrim had better underground
sections
uh yeah I think
so I'm was struggling to think like the
caves and and stuff oh but yeah I I'll
be uh I'll be back in uh two or three
minutes
for
and I am back
already Let's uh defeat this guy
actually by the end of the fight I need
you guys help with something like I'm at
a part in the
script and I feel like I'm forgetting
some stuff so maybe you guys can jog my
memory a little bit we can write that
part of the script together
or at least the notes for
it demon Stone secret
King need to find a to
it how about I just dive straight into
him hey that work
where is he
ow wow that didn't even hurt
me and no I don't have infinite uh like
infinite hearts on on this
time
again I'm going to be running out of
bows real
quick
I think I got him
right
no
almost maybe I can get him from
here oh no it's too
far
ah again you can fly through
him
why do I keep running out of stamina so
quickly think we got him
right
yeah
[Music]
I hate the part where he does the
tornado things I always get hit by
them
ow there we
go eat some
stuff
yeah flying through them is more epic
for
sure oh this part of the music is
awesome
yeah yeah the music is really epic in
this
one yeah it's it's kind of weird how
they don't release the the
OST um but Nintendo does a lot of that
kind of stuff where I'm like you guys
could be making like twice the amount of
money that you are already making if you
just did this but they just don't do it
and I have no idea
why maybe there's they're just not aware
of it or or something close to the
tornado
yeah I get
that don't get too close to the
tornado uh we just eat a raw fish but
that's actually a
waste oh
no
yeah there we
go is he just going to stay like
that oh yeah he's just giving me
time oh I got hurt by that every
time ow uh I shouldn't watch the chat
when I'm playing uh is this
your is this your second
playthrough and the First on stream it
is my second playr yeah I have played
the game on stream before but mostly
just messing around I think not like
actual story
progression I know we did the uh fire
dungeon on stream for
[Music]
sure come on do the
thing
here they come
again yeah
and there he
goes
uhoh
yeah link I think we got
him unless I get hit
by by the asteroids
woo easiest boss
yeah the artwork released after tears of
the Kingdom won the thing at the game
awards would have been uh or should have
been the main box
on yeah I guess so it it it does look
amazing you you mean the one I'm using
for the thumbnail
right the water temple is the easiest
yeah for
sure it's actually funny how they want
you to go to the the reto first this
time instead of the
Zora
tuling it's not my fault I don't have
wings yeah it's must be very easy for
him we're gonna get we're gon to get the
sentence we're g to see the
meme just G to hit record real
quick the whole secret Stone thing is so
stupid but it's become a meme
now
everyone get
ready Ador says I just realized the
other day that we actually got only two
full artworks with the background for of
the Kingdom
yeah it's because the
there's no background art in the uh main
menu which was the case for breath of
wild you you're the one who's been
guiding
us yes Zelda is a dragon by the way I
was there might be good information to
know since you're going to be spending a
lot of time wondering where Zelda
is but you know what I'm not going to
tell you actually never mind I didn't
say
anything I would expect nothing L from
my descendant like why couldn't they
just have a cut scene with this guy this
Sage guy and show how he was like and
what his like the things he did
King he thought he could stop you from
obtaining the that would have been cool
to see my secret
Stone Demon King secret Stone this is a
lotar all there it is I
know but listen while I tell you what
happened in the past it never gets old
war and the mission our people must
accomplish why don't the sages tell us
don't they know yeah they totally know
you can see them standing on the
cliff when Zelda
transforms obviously she would inform
all the sages about her plan because
they kind of Carry On from there they
rise the the Temple of Time up into the
sky
and you know
they like obviously it was supposed to
be part of the
plan there's no way she wouldn't tell
the SES Ed us
Withings secret but the fact that we
actually see them standing
there that was the final nail in the
coffin for me where I was like so these
guys knew knew all this time they could
have easily told us what happened
instead they all just talk they they all
just explained the same cut scene of the
fight with
Ganondorf like did we really need to see
this four times five if you count minu
in the end King Ru realized that we
would not be able to defeat Z Zelda is
really dumb in of the kingdom
riced and seal the king away well that's
what I wanted to list off in a moment
after after this cut
scene it's it's mostly about raru battle
and I would soon receive a visitor with
a request that would define the future
of
burito ganor should have done the sneak
attack again this punch Link in the back
when he's not looking that's just his
main thing now he just sneaks up on
people and punches them to death
breaking their spine with one punch time
aink will oppose just a falcon punch to
the
spine but link will only succeed with
Dorito's help summon the winds and
support this
hero it was clear what part burrito
would play he does the Suave M yeah it
will be an hon to defeat
I swear to you such a good returns good
channelo Sage of wind will awaken more I
think he's one of the few animators who
actually can make it work cuz he he just
gets such insane numbers cuz being an
animator on on YouTube is one of the
hardest things ever unless you have a
team of people and even then it's very
hard to break
even making animation is just so so time
it's it's so time consuming in general
compared to just recording yourself
talking about
something like YouTube is not friendly
to animators at all you must take up my
secret Stone andon Sage of
request fight the it's called warlock
Punch Yeah yeah
true he has a ton of patreons too
yeah even if he didn't have patreons
like his videos are long enough and they
get
such like amazing amount of views that
he can actually make it work but if you
slave away for half a year on one
animation and you only get like 200k
views let's say 250k which is a
respectable amount of views for a video
no don't get me wrong
but that means you can only upload a
video like once every half year or so
cuz even one minute of Animation can
take weeks and weeks to to finish I I
know from my own
experience it's very very time
consuming YouTube is not very friendly
to Dedicated creators at all says a yeah
true given how they've been promoting
Sniper Wolf which is like the bare
bottom of of content creation I am Sage
of wind look check out what I that's
like like bottom of the
barrel like what kind of message does
that send to other creators like oh just
watch other people's videos and comment
on them you don't even have to be funny
or anything
just make it child friendly and just say
like oh wow once in a while and then
there you go fight by your side until
the end you'll be a
millionaire take this it's proof that
I'm with
you to be fair though YouTube isn't
about being fair at
all that is true that is true but it
does says something about how people
consume
content which is a bit of a shame like I
always thought YouTube should be for
people who are creative
who are who have something to offer to
people something more than just sitting
in front of a camera the whole day
and like obviously there's exceptions
like I like uh moist critical cuz he's
just funny use that ring to call my and
I I usually
right am I'm usually is like on the same
wavelength as me when it comes to a lot
of
opinions it it's just insane to me that
there's
channels that are doing so many amazing
things like creative really creative
stuff and then there's Sniper Wolf on
the other side and that's actually the
one who's making more money than all of
them of course it's should all all be
about money in this case
cuz as long as you're having
fun just the fact that you can make
money doing something you love is
already
amazing like back when I was still
making animations on new grounds you
didn't get paid for
that like you got nothing all you got
was like respect from
other other uh like creative wow there's
something going on with the textures up
there we have snow popping in and out of
existence
another another emulator
problem they still haven't gotten this
game to run properly yet still has its
issues man new grounds that's a way back
when yeah yeah yeah for
sure like the only way you got paid on
new grounds back in the day was if you
got sponsored or
something but making it onto the front
page getting thousands of views back
then was just it was all about just
getting
exposure getting respect from from your
peers your fellow
animators but you know it it it was kind
of like a jumping off platform for a lot
of creators like uh ego Raptor started
on new
grounds yeah it is wholesome but you
know artists do like to get paid at some
point so you know new grounds was fun
and it's a great place to or it was a
great place to get experience I don't
know how it is now I haven't been on new
grounds for a long
time but it used to be a great place to
get your stuff out there and receive
some
criticism
improve cuz all the animators I know
they're all they are the most critical
people I know when it comes to their own
work like most animators hate their own
work Captain Doge say I get that I'm
part of a Halo fan game development
project and nobody gets paid for it but
the passion is to make something awesome
and it drives everyone still yeah
yeah and it's a great way to learn
coding like people who make fan games
and continue to grind
they like oftentimes they they have a
chance at getting into real game
development at some
point like quote unquote real as in paid
like as an actual job at a at a studio
or something or as an ID
developer tm2 says the animations you
add to your videos gives it such a
higher level of quality it's
unbelievable well thank you thank you I
mean it's kind of been my Niche I guess
that made me stand out a little
bit and I just love doing it it's it's
just fun usually the animation part of
any Zelda video I make or any video I
make is is the fun part for
me that and the editing seeing it all
come
together all right we did it
[Music]
let me quickly go to Lookout
Landing uh that's oh
here you love making cool thumbnails too
says Ador
uh
sometimes it's a bit of a annoying thing
because I usually do my thumbnails last
and sometimes it holds up the video but
once I get into it into actually making
the thumbnail I do enjoy doing it for
sure where are you going now
uh I don't think we have time to do
another dungeon for
sure uh but I guess we
could get a few of the
memories and I could record those at
least oh and actually the the raru stuff
we can talk about that on next stream
because I want to make a list of all the
things that raru knows but doesn't tell
you but but he totally should tell
you oh I forgot about this
part
crazy to hear how your accent has
subdued so fast it's just
practice anyone can fake an accent if
you if you try like long
enough it it it is really just
practice just listening to other people
talk and how they pronounce certain
words and then at some point you uh and
and recognizing the the things in your
own accent that makes it what it is so
for example uh Dutch people have the
tendency to say so like we have a very
pronounced
s and uh we we have a rolling R so
instead of very we say very I'm very
cool
and you know just recognizing those
parts and changing
them and then with every recording it
just gets less and less until at some
point your accent will
be well I wouldn't say gone but it will
be a lot less
pronounced oh thank you sweet uh sweet
Insanity
7 wait what are you talking
about
if I want to touch the Gloom that's my
that's my
decision Let's uh let's get the
tower you're
Scottish Scottish
Bavarian you you think I you came across
me from zeltic yeah I think a lot of
people zeltic has collab collabed with
in the future and in the past will be
known because of him because he just has
the biggest
audience let's hear your
youtubeist Texas accent oh I don't have
a southern draw draw
draw Southern Southern draw I I usually
to go more into the hillbilly side of it
which is not Texan at all but for some
reason in my mind it kind of that's how
it's always been but that couldn't be
further from what the actual Texas
accent
is right I mean Hillbillies that's not
Texas right where where's what is the
the hillbilly a and where is what area
of the US is that from
is that like Florida
Florida I thought Commonwealth had the
biggest Zelda
audience no zeltic
is by far the biggest Solo YouTube
channel because Commonwealth also does
non Zelda stuff a lot he's just a
general Nintendo YouTuber
also whereas zeltic only does Zelda and
mostly
lore lore and storytelling that's why
that's why when someone says like Z
Zelda stories don't matter I'm like well
how do you explain the biggest solo
Zelda YouTuber who's mainly focused on
lore being that big he should not be
that successful if the stories in Zelda
really didn't matter you
know South Carolina Tennessee likely
Kentucky Tennessee Virginia okay
Hillbilly's are mountain people I think
I thought they were have like the bou
and and things like
that I just know Hillbillies from horror
movies you know like Texas Chainsaw
Massacre all that kind of
stuff which H what
the
well okay
then well zeltic is British British is
automatically you score more points if
you're British when it comes to your
accent
especially especially if you do the
storytelling
stuff I just exploded out of nowhere I
think someone threw a rock at one of the
the the explody barrels or
something I wouldn't say story and lore
are necessarily for hardcore because
what what what defines a hardcore fan to
begin
with I'm running out of bows
but yeah it's definitely not the
majority of the Zelda player base that
that that I definitely do recognize but
it's still a significant part of uh at
least the
Creator side of Zelda I guess like if
you're a Creator you can either be a
speedrunner you can be like you know
like challenge Runner all that kind of
stuff like Focus purely on on
gameplay you can do lore you you can
do like trivia I guess which is both
lore and development
history game
analysis they like there's either way
for each one it's going to be a a
certain
Niche cuz not everyone is into speedr
running but it's still a significant
amount of
people significant enough that there's
money there and there's attention there
and there's people who care about
it damn
Tulin I think I yeah that's it he
did yeah the mix uh a mix is always a
good good idea on YouTube in
general cuz if you only focus your
attention on one thing and that thing
ends up growing stale
or interest goes down for it for
whatever
reason then you're kind of
screwed uh let me
see
no
yes oh Lord heit
coming imagine being an animal crossing
youber you wait five plus
years and you just get one game
yeah yeah you really uh like if
you if you're due tutorial stuff CU
there's not really like big lore there
right like then you have to just do an
Austin John type of thing and just go
with whatever game has a big gains a lot
of traction at that
moment just hammer
out good tutorial videos
and that would not be for me because
it's way too
topical plus I hate making tutorials I
did one tutorial oh no I did one
tutorial for age of Calamity and I was
already tired of it after that people
wanted me to do a guide for every
character I was like I'm not really a
tutorial Channel
though I just thought I would give you
guys a little Basics video about the
comment and that's
it what speed
running well just type in speedr running
um YouTube search bar and find
out
Yeah Austin John his his work ethic is
crazy crazy
good like he will just map out
everything you need to know about a game
and just hammers out videos one after
the
other I don't even think he has an
editor for that I think he all does it
by himself if I
recall maybe he has something to do
research for him but I'm pretty sure he
does his own editing which is quite rare
with those bigger YouTubers at some
point they will hire editors just to
keep up with the content
flow like I'm just one of those weirdos
who continues to do by myself because I
just don't I I just don't want to give
it
away but a lot of bigger YouTubers have
editors who do it for
them yeah he has mad spre uh
spreadsheets for
sure and also one thing to know about
Austin John he is a crazy big Zelda fan
like he loves Zelda he loves the Zelda
Community he loves the Zelda
creators like I'm I met him at
PX and you can just sit down with him
and talk just talk about Zelda for an
hour and he won't mind he he he thinks
it's totally
fine probably the more drunk he gets the
more he wants to talk about it I don't
know but he is a he's a great
guy he was interesting to talk
to I and as for making like Zelda
content I I think that's just not really
his thing
anymore I don't know what he did before
his Pokemon
stuff I've always just known him as the
guy who makes the like all the big
tutorials in the first week when the
game comes out or the first two weeks
whatever oh yeah I forgot about the
fairy
like I don't know Austin John personally
very well aside from that meeting and PX
and hearing about him from other Zelda
creators but I don't I do know he is
genuinely crazy about
Zelda and he likes the Zelda creators
too so he always every convention if the
Zelda people are there he will hang out
with them
always uh where are we going oh yeah I'm
just going to get the
memory well I mean uh
he he chose the path of least resistance
then if he became a Pokemon YouTuber
because it's easier for the the views
because there's always Pokemon games
coming out and and
fast like being a Zelda tuor is not like
every anyone who tries to get into Zelda
don't expect it to be like your big
you're not going to be making millions
let me just put it that
way it's not the easiest choice of
topic you really have to do it because
you care about Zelda because you
actually care about the lore because you
care
about uh talking about the game
researching the game doing whatever
playing the game of course that's why
you do yeah imagine being a Metroid lore
channel that would probably be the only
one that's harder out of Nintendo's big
IPS Maybe Star Fox
Star Fox has been having a bit of a
rough time as well ever since Star Fox
Zero Bandit is literally pivoting
towards
Metroid why he really loves Metroid and
Metroid lore in general so power to him
I think bit just wanted wants to do
whatever he wants to do so when he's
into something he wants to be able to
talk about it so for a while there he
got really into Five Nights at Freddy's
lore they decided to go do Five Nights
at
Freddy's that's that's really cool and I
know Zelda will always have a very
special place for him it's just that
this game is not for him like he he he
likes the Wind Waker storytelling he
likes the arine of
times the the Twilight Princess stuff
that that's that's his
thing so for him this game is Just
Not it just doesn't work for
him at least not for
Content unless it's like a best bosses
top 10 best bosses or something
but you will see that more and more with
some people just kind of skipping out on
this game and being like you know what
it's fine I'll just talk about another
Zelda game in the
meantime yeah he likes deep storytelling
he likes wacky theories he
likes like he
there's a reason why his uh Channel
better is like the mimicking the the the
part with the what's it called like the
white board with all the papers and red
wires running through it I forgot which
I forgot where that's
from is that from Horrible Bosses or
something I know it's Charlie Day
standing in front of a whiteboard or
something you know the meme the classic
meme
but that's him he likes making crazy
connections and finding all sorts of
little things and and that's you
know it's not really in this game
man not not not
really King
raru before you face The Demon King
tomorrow there is something I must tell
you okay let's just see what she has to
say I can't to the S after finding a man
underground go
on when I witnessed what the secret
Stone did to Ganondorf at that moment I
knew for sure oh did you under that was
him you really put that two like two and
two together one day before you faced
The Demon King all the way until my
time in tomorrow's battle
we won't be able to defeat him no matter
how strong we think we are he'll
survive and you and you
will okay so like I get that maybe at
it's only at this moment that she
realizes that the hand is
raru
you know it's a bit obvious to us us so
it's it's a bit like a weird disconnect
here but of course from Zelda's
perspective she only saw the green hand
from like mid distance for the total of
a few seconds Duty and then she fell
into the abyss and all that stuff and
all the crazy things with Gondor started
started happening so I can imagine maybe
she only put that together now just now
and if it proves impossible for to defe
but I find it a bit hard to believe that
she's been in this era for all this time
and only now does she talk about the
story about finding a man underground
you you would think that would be one of
the first things she tells raru like as
soon as she arrives in the past one of
the first like logically speaking one of
the first things raru should be asking
is what are you doing here what where
did you come from what
happened what caused you to be here and
she should immediately you know Spill
the Beans like oh yeah well we went
underground we we found a guy with a
weird arm attached to him and I fell
into a a Chasm I found this Stone and
then I I I even the fact that she has
the same Stone as Sonia they never even
question it they're not like how because
remember in From ru's perspective
the secret stones are secret nobody's
supposed to have them or know about them
except him and
Sonia one of his first reactions should
be where the hell did you get this Stone
like how did you get it get this you're
not supposed to have that nobody is
supposed to know about them
even instead they they're just they
fully accept the fact that she has that
stone that she has the secret stone
that they never really really
ask
anymore like they should have had a
conversation like this much much earlier
when she arrived in the past even if it
was off screen or something like that
instead one day before they actually go
into battle against the demon king then
that's when she finally tells about the
story about what what happened right
before she arrived in the
past
like that's probably my biggest GP with
that
cutscene it's
like it's a mistake that so many stories
make nowadays I don't know if it maybe
it's because I'm I'm paying more
attention to it but I'm I've I've been
watching this series called from just f
r o
m uh which is it's a kind it's a little
bit like lost I guess in a way it has
that same Mystery Box type of feel to
it and one of the worst like I like the
show like I I do actually enjoy it
because it's it's quite creepy it's it's
a it's a fun show but one of the worst
things about that story is people are
not communic like basic information is
not being uh communicated between the
characters for no other reason other
than keeping a mystery so it's not
because of of logical reasons no it's
just because if they would the mystery
would be solved real quick so someone
sees something that is really really
significant and they don't tell anyone
about
it where like why why why are you not
sharing this with
everyone oh hi smart gamer thanks for
dropping
by uh what
what what is another memory that's
relatively close that we can get I think
the one
at
the uh dueling Peaks there's another one
there like a mystery should never be a
mystery because it should be a mystery
because they're either the characters
really don't know
themselves or
even if we know as the audience they
could not possibly know
which I don't know there's
just certain ways to do a mystery and I
I don't know all the rules but I do know
when I see it when it doesn't work where
you're like yeah but the only reason why
this is a mystery is because the writers
wrote wrote it that way not because
there's an actual in universe or in
Universe explanation for it
oh thank you Mickey Mickey Mickey
twice yeah tears of the kingdom is
definitely a te technical Marvel for
sure I
agree cuz despite all the complaining
that I do it's it's because of we're
we're focusing on story right now
because that's what my next video is
going to be about but obviously story is
is but one thing is but it's just one
element what of of a whole package
so most of the other stuff is fine is is
either good or
great I mean obviously it it got
nominated for a game of the year for a
reason clearly this game is doing
something
very very right for
people I just hope that with my video I
can at least convince some people or not
not necessarily convince people but give
people a better understanding or a
better overview of why the the why some
people really really do not like this
story
without having to vilify them for and
just say like oh they're just hating on
the game for the sake of it like nobody
is hating on this game for the sake of
it except people who do not do not like
Zelda in
general like people who see Zelda as
a as overrated or something but every
Zelda fan out there wants to like
everything about this
game I can assure you
that
as a fan of beat him ups I don't know
how he can praise every single segment
of the game well probably because he
just doesn't care about story or doesn't
care about story because not everyone
has an eye for bad or good story writing
that that's just a
fact not to say that I do but I I do
watch people who do so I've kind of
learned
vicariously how to look out for things
but that that doesn't mean that when I
went into this story I was like all
right let's see how I can pick this
apart I I just let it happen but like
about halfway through I was just like
this is just not working for me and I it
took me a while to get all my thoughts
in what like get all my thoughts
straight and figure out why I didn't
like it because feeling something about
something is easy but actually putting
it into words and explaining why you
don't like it that's it's very
difficult very very difficult emotions
are not meant to be translated into
words oh there it
is I don't know which cut scene this is
I think it's the moua one right
because it's shaped like a muga if I
remember yeah no no game is perfect at
the end of the day that's
true and I don't expect anything to be
perfect but I do at
least acknowledge that they could have
been that they could have could have
done a few things a lot better with this
one especially with the
knowledge that they had about breath of
the Wild and the feedback they got on
that
game like how are we not able to pet
dogs it's the worst crime of
all uh where is it again it's so much
easier oh it's right here
okay well exactly uh JJ creeper like
some people really get put off by a bad
story in the video games uh other people
don't other people could not care
less
they're just focused on the gameplay
itself they don't even let you pet dogs
just out of spite
yeah they just like screw these people
cool all right can someone explain this
part to me real real
quick uh cuz I I'm either going to
mention it in my video or I'm not going
to mention it in my video but how are
these muga supposed to pose any danger
to them they're on a they're on the
great Plateau right there's no sand
there it's a like are they just all
going to slam into the
wall and then I don't know the wall
breaks and falls down like what was
their plan here
exactly what was their plan of attack on
the on this one cuz as far as I know
muga can only survive in sand that's why
they're not in other parts of hyru and
you know the great Plateau is mostly
Rock and grass and it's elevated with a
giant
wall oh they could fly back then okay
gotcha they just leap out of the the
sand and just flop around on the on the
on the great Plateau until everyone's
dead I don't know if it's going to be
worth it to mention that in the video
may maybe just for as I like
uh maybe for like a a comedic bit cuz I
do want the video to be lighthearted in
in a lot of areas I don't want it to be
just me complaining and being super like
spiteful or hateful towards the the my
complaints or the the story in general I
also want it to be funny because bad
writing can also lead to very comedic
moments and then with
fiction the the like if you get some
like real life historical fact
completely wrong in your writing like
that's bad but in fiction you can make
plenty of mistakes it doesn't really
matter cuz at the end of the day it's
not going to impact your life in any
way you feel bad for the
mouas why is Zelda's shiny hand thingy
bigger than Sonia's I think because she
has raru and Sonia's pow so she has
double double the or it's a Triforce I
don't know know at this point I'm I'm
not even sure
anymore I I kind of like I still kind of
like my theory that she does have the
full Triforce but since they did not
explore that part at
all I think you only see it on her hand
once when she's charging up the sword I
I
believe but that that's about it the
there's no other they don't explore that
part
do you believe Sonia and raru had a
child a child well they they kind of had
to
right they quite literally say that they
have a blood
connection and that she has both time
powers and light powers from both of
them so that it's pretty much the only
the only option at this point right that
they are related in some way which
is kind of weird because they both
die Queen Sonia is a furry good for her
though it's the ABS man the the raru has
crazy ABS would would drive any woman
crazy I'm pretty
sure yeah I don't know if the the the
hero's aspect has anything to do
with a z like in general just the Zone
ey because the zonai don't have tails
and they don't have red hair as far as
we
know like how can you get how can you
have two species without a tail and get
a species with a tail unless the zonai
have different forms or
something but that's you know that's the
confusing part that people are just
going to have to figure
out I think there's a cave under
this all
righty
[Music]
Jesus oh my God the
shipping they're
shipping I mean everyone should do
whatever they want but I still find
shipping so weird in this
game in general I'm not a big shipping
guy
because in my opinion it's it can
sometimes ruin I've seen I've seen
entire shows get ruined by shipping
because at some point it was more
important uh like narratively it seemed
to become more important who ended up
with who than you know actually telling
a good
story if you enjoy shipping that that's
it's not meant to be a stab at you
but it's not for
me I don't even ship people in real life
let alone fictional fish people and
other an anthropomorphic
characters
to be fair FES are Z zonai Rito and
Zoras aren't Zoras scales or something
like
that cuz they have
scales I thought those were two
different things but maybe that's just
me oh there we
go such a time
wasting hey hey mon what what did you
think about setting setting tears of the
Kingdom story in the past where we play
as Zelda in a more Primal Hyrule that
would have been
great it's what some of us were hoping
for right
like a playable
Zelda I have to open the door first
huh
can you open the door oh yeah there's a
there's a thing
here I can just grab
it is there another one oh there's
another
one who put these sticks
here was it Ganondorf did that did
Ganondorf put these sticks here to mess
with
us
it's all part of the
plan link the hero of
doors actually I made a tweet about
something related to Zelda and dors not
too long ago I think it was last summer
it's like canonically it actually makes
sense that na'vi has to explain to link
how to open a door in aine of time when
he's in the decut
tree because there are no doors in Kiri
forest or the Lost Woods anywhere
so link literally never saw a door in
his whole life
so when when he finally goes into the
Decker tree that that is the first time
he ever sees a door so someone has to
explain to it to him how it
works that was just a joke Theory I
should have made a short of that or
something but I heard shorts are
actually bad for the algorithm or
something if your channel is more long
form and you do shorts supposedly the
algorithm doesn't like that but I I I I
personally I think it's it's probably
[__]
but I do want to do more shorts in the
future because it will be an easy way to
get small little ideas like that out
there it's just it's just getting it
under one minute it's so difficult h
so many NPCs have the same voice sounds
yeah like he had a boy's voice that
voice I will always know that as Boosey
the the creepy guy in front of
uh in front of gudo
town
there are no doors ciri forest or Lost
Woods anywhere holy
bleep
yeah it's all just holes that you walk
into just holes in the wall or in the
tree
trunks like it's not until you get to
the Forest Temple that you see the first
door or inside the the the gray Decker
tree what would that be like to see a
door for the first time in your
life cuz you know you were you were just
a tiny kid when that kind of stuff
happened for the first
time so that it just automatically you
know but as an adult if you never seen a
door in your life how would that impact
you would you just be staring at a door
knob and being like
huh yeah walls
move oh oh I'm out of
stamina I do think I have that last
saving like Saving
Grace paraglider pull out thingy that
you can
do
[Music]
uh if I can see the actual ground oh
God
yeah and then just walk away like a
badass like I meant
that it was all part of the
plan I I actually want to go to lurin
Village cuz that's where the the cut
scene of Ganondorf punching like warlock
punching uh Sonia
is or I guess I could just load up my
100% save
file then I just have access to all the
memories
but actually I should probably get the
other one
first
do you have a theory why in Kiri Forest
bark inside
houses Oh you mean there's bark tree
bark on the inside of the house yeah
that doesn't make much sense unless it's
like a purpose purposely done
decoration like I strip the bark outside
and put it inside the
house
yeah breath the wild is still
fantastic it's still
great it's a it's actually a bit of a
shame that people now kind of bash
on on on uh breath the wild like oh
there's no reason to play it anymore
because this
exists but you know it is what it
is uh can I
just build a boat real quick or
something I do have fans but I don't
have
wood I can just walk around
it actually what is the fastest way to I
think I'm better off just going back to
look at
Landing uh gun to the head would you
take two tears of the Kingdom or breath
what would you take I'm I'm assuming you
mean tears of the Kingdom or breath of
wild to a deserted
island
[Music]
uh it's kind of hard to
say I I mean I do know breath the wild
better than this game like I know every
side quest every collectible everything
cuz over the years I've just been
playing through it and recording footage
and doing Quests for such a long time
that I
know much more about the game than this
one I'm pretty sure I haven't even done
all the side quests in this
game so I I would probably pick this one
just because there's more stuff I'm
unfamiliar
with
but I do prefer breath wild at least in
terms of the impact it had on me bre
wild is definitely like breath is in my
top five tears of the kingdom is
not and I'm it's that's not just because
of story stuff it's
just it's very derivative
so obviously the impact was going to be
lessened unless they did something
completely different with it but they
it's just more breath
Wild for the most
part for me impact has more meaning than
just is it bigger is it better or does
it have more
quests just my per my first playthrough
of of breath the wild was just just so
magical I had never played a an open
world like that
before yeah the game has plenty of
content to like just keep yourself
entertained for a long time for
sure it's just that in my like what
where comes to games in my top whatever
lists it's not necessarily the biggest
games or the games with the most things
in
them it's also just the overall impact
it had on
me and Brew just had way more impact on
me than than this game
did
it's actually easier to just walk around
like this not not having to do much I
can I can easily rehat like this like
this
uh there's a grasses Greener
mentality uh in what context do you mean
like now that we have this game we
suddenly want to go back
or oh anuma says
that yeah but I I don't really trust the
whole translation stuff I do they even
have a saying like that like the grass
is greener on the other side do they do
they have a
saying like that in Japanese I don't
know like I don't really see anuma as
the bad guy in this
situation I think it's just the general
focus of the team as a whole has kind of
shifted For Better or For Worse depends
on how you look at
it what are my top five Zelda games uh
that would
be bre the wild AR of time it's not in
any order but
uh yeah bre wild AR of time maurus
mask uh Wind
Waker Twilight Princess I guess
currently and that's only 3D games cuz
2D games I kind of count those separate
because I don't think it's fair to p a
3D Zelda game against a 2d Zelda game
because there are 2D Zelda games that I
prefer over some of the 3D
titles Like A Link to the Past is
still freaking
amazing Minish Cap is great albe it a
bit little bit
short Link Between Worlds was really
good
too it was everything a 2d Zelda game
needs to be pretty
much I think the only part of the link
between worlds I don't like is the fact
that the difficulty scaling is a bit off
because you can do everything in any
order but there's I don't really see how
they could have fix that to be
honest because you can just rent any
item and go to any dungeon whenever you
want to pretty much
so it's a
tradeoff yeah Link to the Past is great
I also have very very good memories of
the Oracle games like the the the time
period in which I played the Oracle
games was just such a great
time
like two Zelda games in the same like
released on the same day like are you
crazy what's my favorite video I've ever
made
uh oh that's I I cannot really look at
my own content that
way I I do sometimes rewatch old content
just to learn from or
just you know cuz sometimes you you'll
find new sometimes you grow as a Creator
you grow in the wrong direction for a
little while we're like man I used to
have more humor in my older videos or I
used to do this better in my older
videos so sometimes it does help to
watch your own content once in a while
but I guess in terms of the video I had
the most fun making was definitely life
as ablin because a I didn't have to do
the voice voice over and be it was just
really fun to capture all the
[Music]
footage uh I think I have to climb the
tower
right
all
right can I recall any of this
stuff no cannot recall
this I'll just recall that one
then
we need a sequel
to
what if you had to choose what which
Zelda game you want to see as a movie uh
probably a enough time is because that
that one kind of sets the the the basics
it has all the the things that a Zelda
movie probably should
have except do it better because even
though I think I still think the story
of uh arine of time is really good
mostly because of subtext and just you
know the the the Chic twist was really
good but our of times subex is probably
what makes the story the best overall
the whole idea of time being cruel
creepy by like coming of age
things it's a really solid setup for for
a
story Life as a bobble in the
movie oh we need a sequel
too uh life I get
it
maybe someday if I have a good idea for
it uh chat Nation H chat Nation says
honestly good blood's video on arine of
Time Master Master Class of
subtext uh made me view arine of time in
a whole new light and I'm super
appreciative that yeah I think for most
of
most of us that was kind of an eye
opener like wow this story actually is
so much more layered so much more deep
if you're willing to look past the
relatively simple
story because let's be honest it is a
very simple story at the end of the day
uh if you only look at the the
progression part of
it like even Ganondorf had almost zero
character
development he just wants to rule you
just wants the
Triforce and then once he finally does
he kind of just sits on a on his throne
for the rest of the story he doesn't
even try to get the other two Triforce
pieces he's like well they'll just come
to me
eventually so it's not a perfect story
but it I for that time for the first 3D
Zelda I think it was an amazing
story and I think that one would
translate the best into a movie I think
a story like mro mask for example is too
weird it's not mainstream enough
to get people into
it simple stories can be fine too
doesn't always have to be complex you
don't need hundreds and hundreds
of twists and turns and all that crazy
stuff not a professional Zelda lore
guy I mean nobody is a professional
Zelda lore guy if you really think about
it at the end of the day
it's we all get stuff wrong about
it Zelda 1 had no story technically it
did but it's kind of tucked away in the
manual and it's quite an interesting
it's very very very very basic this is
definitely not from this
era that said I believe there may be a
way to get the travel functionality
working
here I'd like to Tinker with it a bit
would it be okay if I borrow it yes
whatever you need I really appreciate
your help
hold so you really believe my story that
I came from the future uh abber Eber The
Legend of Zelda says hey monster maze
what are your thoughts on the next
game being a direct
sequel like
some stone that allowed people have been
saying sorry it's scrolling while I'm
reading it's so
annoying let me lock it uh like some
people have been saying that they are
glad because they don't uh they want
everything new new Link new Zelda new
G yeah the next one should definitely
not be a sequel I think she can control
town world has run its course as for you
I can sense this world and these
characters have definitely run their
course I think it's time for something
new something fresh your secret Stone
seems to amplify your time power I don't
really see where they could take this
story after
this ultimately the secret Stone only
amplifies your power definitely no
moreon no gr you master let the past be
still up to
you that means you don't already know
how and definitely a completely new map
even if it's going to be the same
characters I want a completely different
world at the very least and hopefully a
little bit different a bit of a
different gameplay Loop this time called
draconif cuz if we we have to do the
same thing again again cororo seeds
again unlocking M the map through
Towers I don't know if I can do it a
third time man I don't know if I have
energy for that so you think these
stories could hint at a solution to our
there has to be other ways and I'm sure
there are and they can find out but
there other ways to to create a Zelda
game Zelda story a Zelda
world that's different from this one
that is why it is
forbidden I thought maybe this could
lead to a solution there are no plans
for a sequel anyway the devs already
confirmed that well DLC at least they're
not going to do DLC we don't know what
they're going to do in terms of the next
game I'm sorry I wish I could help
more like on the one hand I can kind of
see that they're like well we do already
we already have voice actors for these
characters so there still maybe we can
use them one more time but if they do I
want it to be in a very very different
context no more zai no more High rule
son would be happy to help
you okay
JJ creeper says stupidest memory ever I
can think of a few that are more stupid
though this one is actually quite tame
it's
just lore
Exposition they're kind of spitting
their wheels a little
bit but I think this one is
harmless
I wasn't paying attention actually was
this the one where she hints at the
dronification she spoils the twists kind
of in a
way
uh let's see let's just go back to the
tower okay that that was it okay that at
that part I was reading
chat
minu was already holding the switch too
yeah it's going to be even more
slim I want the next Zelda game to be
weird and
different not too sure if we're going to
get another weird one anytime soon cuz
from what I understand a lot of the
weirdness of games
like um Mid mask and uh linkx awaken
I think that's all because of one
guy I forgot his name again I wrote it
down
too I'm sure someone in chat remembers
who who it
was something with an S his last
name Kumi oh it was not it was not an s
yeah Kumi is the the the one responsible
for the for the weirdness in those
games from what I understand at
least maybe it's also just don't feel
confident enough to do another one of
those CU as
much as people love mad's
mask people also kind of forget
sometimes that it only s it it literally
sold
half of uh arrine of times numbers which
is kind of crazy
for the sequel to one of the most
successful games of that era you would
you would expect everyone to line up for
the next one especially since it's the
new art uh the same art style same
system so it people didn't even have to
get a new
system and yet it only sold
half it's kind of
crazy and then of course the 3DS remix
came out and the same thing happened
again maduro's mask 3D only sold half of
arine of Time
3D so maybe they're just like
well I mean I guess that would send the
message at least a little bit oh I'm
dead oh
no
almost 2030 seems so far away it is far
away it's more than six
years
I'll be in my 40s by that
point people didn't get Ma's mask at the
time yeah
maybe I mean
ultimately again at least to me impact
is more
important than sales
numbers CU if you look at the best
selling movies of all
time many of them are not particularly
like masterpieces and yet they still
sold incredibly well like I think
Jurassic world for example is like one
of the highest grossing movies
ever and I don't think anyone would ever
argue in their lifetime that it it's
better than Jurassic Park the original
Jurassic
Park the 3DS remake is inferior to the
original are you purely talking maor's
mask or also aren of
time because I do think both
remakes have their
merits some things about them are are
just really well
done but yeah some of the things like
the Zora swimming
and you know some of the streamlining
they did yeah I
agree they they didn't have to change
the any of those things
[Music]
I don't like how twin mold is literally
bugged in a 3DS oh yeah some of the boss
changes were pretty outrageous
too but like the graphics for example I
love how detailed the environments are
once you get used to the
details like the graphics the details
especially if you emulate it on uh like
four times native in the what's it
called
again uh not simu the other one
Citra like then it it really looks it
it's kind of hard to go back after that
to the old environment cuz the old
environments are so boring compared to
the the new
ones but yeah there's also a lot of
things that you will miss if you only
play the uh the the 3DS remake for
sure there's there there's just certain
things that bug me about the the 3DS
remakes including aine of time like the
some of the character animation on link
it just doesn't feel the same
like even the even something as simple
as Link's walk
cycle in the original it just felt like
it had weight behind it and in in the
3DS remak it almost feels like he's ice
skating like he's floating like there's
no weight to it it's very hard to
explain it's like an animation thing but
I think I think a lot of people did
feel it like they they might feel that
way but they don't know exactly why they
feel that
way there's just something off about the
way he
runs I have no idea where I'm going at
this point by the way I think I'm just
uh oh it's already almost midnight
here I've we've been doing some crazy
long streams I think it's actually in
general a good time to call it quits
because my voice is almost entirely
gone uh we'll talk about the raru stuff
next uh stream which is either going to
be Saturday or
Sunday because I still have a lot of
writing and notes before I actually
start working on the video proper at
least on the
script yeah yeah my voice is fine it's
just it it's just worn
down it's
gone plus it's midnight I have to keep
my sleeping schedule healthy I finally
have it back like the the game awards
really messed up my sleeping
schedule I for some reason I I told
myself I wasn't going to watch it or
stream it or do whatever I I said I was
going to like
be a grownup and just sleep in time and
then I was laying in bed and I could not
help myself I had to
know whether or not tears of the Kingdom
won any anything I wanted to see if they
would announce like DLC like I even made
a community post about it like hey guys
I'm not going to be watching it I'm
going to be uh I'm going to be
responsible so this year no
stream and then I still ended up
watching parts of it while I was laying
in
bed and after that my sleeping schedule
was all the way back to screwed up again
it took me weeks to correct
it
h Sunday is your birthday well then we
will do a uh oh Saturday is your
birthday I'm sorry I I wrote
I for some reason
I it's late it's getting late
Saturday is your birthday then I guess
we'll stream on Saturday
then cuz Sunday is Charlie is also
streaming on Sunday I don't want to
steal his
fans but yeah I will I will stream on
Saturday then Saturday uh same time as
today 8:00 pm my time which I don't know
it's like 1 p.m. or 2 p.m. EST
oh Charlie that's the one of my friends
chapi he's been a a guest on on my some
of my videos in the
past very
briefly but yeah thanks as always for uh
dropping by to my weirdly boring
streams where I complain about
things yeah we'll we'll continue this
next time we'll do a couple more
memories and uh at least one of the
dungeons next
time well glad to hear it's not boring
then uh one last question Hinton
Empire monster maze did you see the
video about the hero's shade not being
the hero of time
seems like a good one for you guys to
respond
to uh I mean what is it called what
what's the
title let me check real quick is it just
hero shade is not a hero of
time is it the most controversial
character I don't know what it's called
Uh oh is that one I actually watched
half of it
unknowingly it's the one that has a
thumbnail that says lies
right I will I will give it a watch and
maybe there is something to it since I
am doing a
hero shade video of my own at some point
I already have a thumbnail even which I
showed on the last stream actually but
yeah thank you so
much thanks everyone for dropping by
we'll do this again later this
week all right good good to hear that
it's at least been
fun
oh hey there Gabriel I'm about to leave
so next
time next week we we'll we'll stream
again on Saturday Saturday 2 p.m EST I
guess 8:00 P.M C if you're in my time
zone all right thanks everyone and uh I
will see you next
time
bye-bye